and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Twilight Breaking Dawn
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
will you merely my spoilers there's this
girl who's marrying a blood sucking
vampire that's what most women think
they're marrying any week but it turns
out her other boyfriend a werewolf boy
she knows how to pick up is Jonas
because he wants or - oh come on guy
keep your shirt on
seriously keep you sure there it goes
one second and it's gone it has to be a
new record for these movies but Bella is
still so happy that she's marrying the
vampire n-word I think it's kind of
weird it's the happiest day of her life
animal touch she has a limp which girl
it's her wedding finally smile for once
look even Edward is smiling that awkward
smile and that's really uncomfortable
but at least he's smiling
how can I smile when there's just so
much drama and grief in my life oh oh
Edward you can have so it wouldn't be a
finally get married and Edward has a
little surprise for her hey Bella
remember why I dumped you for a while
yeah and you started getting the hots
for that one boy yeah he had the hots
for you yeah but you totally dumped him
because you're a cock tease yeah
and yet for some reason you constantly
act like you're interested in him even
though you're getting married to me yeah
and he got so frustrated with that that
he decided not to show up to your
wedding at all yeah where's your Hughes
he oh I totally have no idea how to feel
right now swell the script says happy
cake so we're done Jacob are like dude
I'm totally gonna weigh that girl that
you have a hots for
yeah thanks but aren't you afraid
they're gonna hurt her don't worry we're
usually protection guyhnic the trust
that I will never endanger her life wait
a minute you're not even using birth
control
oh no well what does she get printed oh
please how many couples who had sex
without protection actually get pregnant
most one the teenager it's my job to
make stupid mistakes like this and blame
my parents for it what does she see in
that guy so hey we're Tibetan go on
their honeymoon and rock the bed
in that it looks like someone threw
rocks at the bid I mean holy smokes the
room looks destroyed imagine what sex
with a female vampire is like yeah it
turns out that Becky's pregnant
hey those bats can swim and both Bella
and Edward are like oh is this possible
can it be possible
who is sex does usually lead to cute oh
gee she sounds just like that Jacob guy
wish I'd married him once but it turns
out they don't exactly know what's
growing inside her really nobody knows
what's growing inside me never in the
history of mankind as a vampire ever
made more to a human and gotten her
pregnant I find that very hard to
believe why does this mean so Bella is
possibly giving bread - I have human
half vampire hybrid Oh
oh my god she's giving birth to blade
it's open season on all sparklers please
do that twist I would love you forever
if you put that twist in there but new
it turns out the baby inside is trying
to care imagine anyone that close would
want to kill her but Edward is like
don't worry we're going to get that
thing out of you well clearly you're
behind me on this because I'm your
husband and you just agree with me you
see how because obviously nobody has any
other say and there's no other choice in
the situation
well Nikki I make the choice I'm so glad
we agreed to get rid of that little
abomination inside of you don't try to
make me feel better I'm so distraught I
better word coming yet what a thought
getting married at such a young age
would somehow work against me my bad
words yeah but Bella decides that she
does want to keep the baby and so she's
like I knew it's a boy isn't it but I
feel it it feels like a boy no really
it's not if it to hit in the script it's
a girl oh you probably have crossed that
out of the script yeah so Edward has a
little talk with Jacob
I want you to talk to her to get rid of
the baby whiny because for some reason
she trusts you even more they aren't you
married to her yes this is turning into
a real marriage remember don't jacob
tries to talk to her but she's not
getting rid of the baby so Jacob decides
to fight on their side you see all the
other werewolves want to kill her
because of this but Jacob is gonna stand
by her side and she still gets the chef
doesn't he I still get the chef don't I
you even though clearly I've risk a much
more sacrificing much more I love you
much more ah
did you forget Edward stares at me wait
am I gonna get over you so
this big battle between the werewolves
and the vampires Oh while the BP is
beating the shit out of her mother just
to get the hell out pretentiousness and
so the baby is born but it kills Bella
in the process the girls start crying
and all the boys break out the champagne
but I never what is like maybe if I buy
the rafter she's dead that'll somehow
bring her back to life I don't think
that's Helen it's Twilight yeah so why
Edward stars binding her to Jacob
imprints himself onto the baby girl
meaning the Wolves can't harm her
anymore and Jacob is bound to her
forever a Freudian liad so all the wear
was gone me the baby girl is totally
safe and Bela finally turns into a
vampire I am going to sock you plant it
and so I'm really excited to know that
this is only part one because so many
teenage girls deserve to see part two
after all we talked about marriage sex
and abortion all the things we know
Twilight will be fantastic at talking
about clearly has a mature logical
understanding of the teenage female mind
or at least how to make a profit on it
this is jittery bun saying guys you got
change that come on I'm a guy are we up
tonight change hey Bella I have a
question does he sparkle down there